. Oh, dabei! Hey, schön, dass ihr da seid. Wir warten noch ein bisschen, bis hier noch alle aufgeräumt haben. Dann sind wir da. Ich kann nicht mehr. Seitenstechen. Was macht man gegen Seitenstechen? Hi, das geht. Na, hey. Wow, was eine doofe Idee. Hallo Mainz, seid ihr da? Seid ihr gut drauf? Schön, hallo, danke schön. Hi, hallo. Niemand ist dabei. Habt die erste Reihe nicht mehr drauf und dann machen wir den und es sieht aus wie ein nahbares Stars. Wie geht's euch meins? Vor allem, wir sind so stolz, dass ihr da... Du bist wirklich außer Atem. Ja. Wir sind so stolz, dass ihr da seid und nicht beim Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag unterwegs seid. Wie sehr ärgert es euch, dass ihr nicht daran gedacht habt, dass ja heute auch der Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag ist. Scheiße, ist Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag. Und hier drin sein müsst, während draußen ganz Rheinland-Pfalz tobt. Ja genau, draußen ist mega Stimmung. Ich bin auch schon ein bisschen eingetaucht
ins rheinland-pfälzische Leben.
Da ist einmal was los, ne, und dann
sei der hier. Ich verzichte hier auf das grosse
Sanitäter-Zelt, um die beiden laufen zu sehen.
Dafür habe ich nicht...
Ich glaube, für dich brauchen wir gar nicht Sanitäter-Zelt.
Ja, haben wir Sanitäter da?
Sich kurz hinlegen.
Wir haben auch schon gesagt,
es ist ein bisschen so heute so ein Messetagungsfeeling. Es sagt alles weniger Comedy aus, als wir erzählen euch was über die neueste Dentalchirurgie-Praxis. Richtig, denn hassten Sie es nicht auch, wenn Ihre Patienten vor der Tür stehen und immer diese merkwürdigen Spritzgeräte in den Mund brauchen? Nein, heute wird Dentalmedizin revolutioniert mit dem Dentalcare 2000.
Schön, dass ihr da seid. Es wäre so gut, wenn jetzt das aufbindet, dahinter wäre der Dentalcare 2000.
Nein, wir sind heute auf der Tagung für Moltonstoff, das ist dieser Stoff.
Ja, viele kennen die Vorteile schon, aber schaut mal, wie ihr jubelt, wenn wir euch zeigen, wie Molton 2.0 aussieht.
Es ist noch schwerer, noch undurchdringlicher und noch schwerer. Noch staubiger auch. Es ist noch staubiger, es ist noch ungewaschener. Meins, was ist los? Ohne Scheiss, guck mal. Was treibt ihr hier drin, dass ihr Staub bis da oben hinkriegt? Vor allem, ich dachte gerade, vielleicht ist es ein Unrelatable Joke, weil ich stehe direkt davor. Aber alle habenacht und dann lachte ich mir, okay, also alle sehen diesen Staub. Und niemand hier hat sich überlegt, ich meine, das heißt Rheingoldhalle. Und dann hat man sich nicht überlegt, den Molten ein bisschen schön zu machen. Es ist schön, es soll ein Sternenhimmel sein, weil wir sind ja ein UFO und das ist ein Sternenhimmel. Das kann man immer sagen, das ist immer meine Ausrede, wenn ich irgendwie Flecken auf dem T-Shirt habe oder so. Das ist ein Sternenhimmel. Das ist ein Sternenhimmel. Da sind einfach ein paar Joghurtflecken drauf, das passt schon, das zieht sich gerne einfach ein. Warst du ein bisschen schon am Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag unterwegs? Ja, herrlich, es war wunderschön, es war wirklich ein Traum. Wie lange hast du heute angenommen, das ist der Main und nicht der Rhein? Ja, ich hatte mir, okay, wir machen mal kurz die Schublade der verworfenen Gags auf, voller Charme. Ja, und ich bin direkt so ein Bulli-Typ, der erzählt mir was privat backstage und ich komme raus und sage, er hat gedacht, das ist der mein. Ich dachte folgendes, okay, ihr müsst euch jetzt wirklich in so ein Stand-Up, so Berliner Open-Mike-Mindset reingehen. Ja, ja, geht mal in Comedy-Mindset rein. Ja, geht mal aus dem Dentalmesse-Mindset. Ja, ja Geht mal aus der Dentalmesse raus. Und einfach so, ist euch schon mal aufgefallen, dass wir in Mainz leben? Die Stadt liegt an einem Fluss namens Main, liegt Mainz, ich meine, wie unkreativ kann man eine Stadt nennen? Ist ja so, wie wenn Köln Rheins heißen würde.
Aber ich glaube, das war auch meine grösste Angst vor meinem allerersten Stand-Up-Auftritt.
Dass es faktisch inkorrekt ist.
Genau, waren diese Fänd-ihr-das-Momente, wo dann alle sagen, nein.
Ich hätte auch als Mario Barth wahnsinnige Angst, weil vielleicht nur meine Freundin die Fernbedingungen auf dem Fernseher legt.
Ja, genau. Und alle anderen machen das ganz anders. Das Olympiastadion ist komplett leise. Still, still. Ja, Rheingoldhalle, komplett leise. Ich glaube, in der Paralleldimension ist es richtig gut angekommen, wo der tatsächlich mein heisst. Aber Stefan hat mich aufgeklärt, dass er nicht mein heisst, sondern eins. Da habe ich auch gedacht, wow, unkreativ kann es Stadt heissen. Aber ich dachte gerade, gibt es bei so Dentalmessen, ich weiß nicht, warum wir uns da aufgehangen haben, so Ärztetagungen, wo wir basically gerade sind, optisch zumindest, haben die auch so Stand-Ups abends, um die Stimmung so ein bisschen aufzulockern? Auf jeden Fall ein monothematisches Art-Stand-Up. Ja, ich glaube, es gibt zu jedem speziellen Berufsfeld einen ganz speziellen Stand-Up-Comedian, der dann immer kommt und dann einfach die Zahn-Gags macht. Und dann einfach so, kennt ihr das, wenn wirklich B4 und B5 wirklich so stehen? Und alle so, ja genau, ja genau. Und er hatte die Achter noch nicht raus. Und ich meine, Weisheitszähne, hallo, was soll das denn? Wo kommen die her? Wohl eher dumme Zähne. Wohl eher Cash-Heiz-Zähne. Genau, am I right? Am I fucking right? Versteht ihr? Weiß ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung, ob die Geld verdient. Weiß ich auch nicht, genau. Also auf jeden Fall schwierig. Hast du deine Achter raus? Achter raus, Neuner raus, ich habe gesagt, nehmen Sie gleich alle raus. Nehmen Sie. Gleich alle raus. Alle ab acht raus. Je weniger Zähne, desto weniger Probleme, würde ich sagen. Ich will eigentlich nur, weil ich wollte auch gerade in der Phase, in der ich eine Zahnspange hatte, immer Vampir werden. Und dann dachte ich mir, kann man nicht da so beim Zahnarzt mal so einen Push geben, so in eine Richtung. So im Sinne von, ja, mir werden, die sind halt so ein bisschen kurz geraten, oder so die hier. Kann man da nicht ein bisschen was machen, in der Hoffnung, dass er sagt, ja, ja, klar, natürlich, und die müssen länger werden. Oder so gelangweilt, ah, Sie wollen das Edward-Programm haben und dann so zur Arzthelferin, er will ein Neunachtziger haben und sie sagt, okay. Ab dann nehmen Sie den Becher auch nicht an den Wasserhahn, sondern den Bluthahn und er war so, okay, sagen Sie das doch gleich. Ja, das Blut, was bei mir abgepumpt wird, wenn ich so eine Zahnspülung, okay. Oh ja, genau. Hallo, das ist eine ärzte Tagung, das ist eine ärzte Tagung, bei Blut alle ... Iiiiih, Blut ... Bauen eine Triggerwarnung ein. Aber ich meine, ist das nicht auch ein Plothole in Twilight oder so, dass die nie zum Zahnarzt gehen können, weil sie dann sofort in Haft werden würden? Ach so, ich hätte Plothole im Sinne von ... Also weil ich glaube, noch im Zahn eines Vampirs ist, glaube ich, ein grosses Problem. Ja, weil die bleiben ja immer am selben Ort, damit es nicht auffällt, dass die altern und dann können die aber auch da nie zum Zahnarzt gehen, weil der Zahnarzt so, ja, B4, B3, B, what the fuck, da ist ein, ja, hatten wir schon mal die Diskussion, haben Vampire Löcher in den Zähnen, die das egal. Nee, nee, ich will es wissen. Wir müssen jetzt den Raum teilen, wir müssen schon möglichst früh polarisieren. Read the room, Florentin. Wir müssen, bevor wir jetzt weitermachen mit den Vampir-Gags, wissen, worüber lacht Mainz. Ja genau, wir müssen jetzt den Raum spalten. Was glaubt ihr? Es gibt zwei Optionen, entweder Vampire haben die Löcher in den Zähnen. Und saugen Blut aus Zähnen raus oder sie beißen nur die Wunde und saugen dann mit dem Mund ganz normal aus, wie man das kennt, wie Babys zuzeln würde. Also nicht wie Babys Blut saugen, sondern wie Babys eine Flasche saugen. Wir haben Team Loch und wir haben Team Saugen. Alles klar. Wer ist Team Loch? Einmal Hand hoch. Ich kriege schon viel Enthaltung hier an der Stelle. Das merkt man oft schon am ersten Wahlgang, dass da eine Menge Enthaltung mit dabei ist. Wer ist Team Saugen? Oh, wow! What the hell? Wer ist Team ist mir scheißegal. Eine Person, eine Person. Nee, nee, es waren deutlich mehr. Ach so, zwei Personen. Ganz linke Seite, scheißegal. Wer denkt, wem von euch ist es noch egaler als dem anderen? Ja, okay, die Person. Okay, ein bisschen zu spät. Die ist natürlich am alleregalsten. Das haben wir jetzt schon geklärt. Die saugen dran? Ja, die saugen dran. Aber dann hättest du doch, die These, was dagegen spricht, ist halt, du hättest nicht nur zwei Löcher, sondern du hättest dann auch noch einen Bluterguss. Und auch noch einen Knutschfleck drauf. Und so ein Stück Spinat oder sowas. Du denkst so, ach, Alter, mach dir mal die Zähne sauber. Du hättest einen Knutschfleck. Ja. Im Grunde schon. Ich glaubte das immer noch oder haben jetzt Leute ihre Meinung geändert? Das ist deine Aufgabe für heute. Du versuchst die Tendenz einfach auf die andere Seite zu kippen. Also ja, ein unangenehmer Abend dann, monothematischer Abend dann, Vampirmesse. Ja, das ist schwierig, die gerade die, vom Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag habe ich nicht viel mitbekommen, ich versuche ja immer so den Raum zu lesen, immer so ein bisschen, was ist das hier für eine Veranstaltung und ich bin nur, bin nur reingegangen und da grosse Menschenmenge, verschiedene Zelte und ein Zelt war einfach so eine Gummipuppe, wo man so trainieren kann, Leute wiederzubeleben. Ja, stay in the life, stay in the life. Einfach so ein kniete, so ein sechsjähriges Kind davor, das mit ganzer Körperkraft auf die Brust gehauen hat und ich dachte mir so, ich habe genug gesehen, das reicht mir, das ist der Tag in einer Vignette zusammengefasst, das reicht mir schon und der Sanitär da so mit so einem, immerhin interessiert sie sich für Medizin, ich meine meine, er will wirklich und dann irgendwann, das wäre ein geiler Pottes, wenn die Puppe plötzlich aufwacht und sagt, weil noch nie hat jemand so doll auf sie eingeschlagen. Die Puppe so, okay, ich weiß, ich bin Profi, aber das tut fucking weh gerade. Ich halte echt viel aus, aber das tut gerade wirklich weh. Aber was ist eine geile Geschichte über dieses Kind dann plötzlich, weil es ist ja noch nicht im Ersthilfealter, oder? Also es wäre ein bisschen ein merkwürdiges Bild, wenn irgendwer draußen umkippt und als erstes läuft so ein kleines Kind dahin und praktiziert perfekt Herzrhythmusmassage. Das ist so durchdringend, so I got this, okay, das ist mein Moment, das ist Claras Moment einfach. Und dann mit dem kleinen Armen. Bap, bap, bap, erlebt, erlebt. Aber es macht Sinn auf eine Art, weil er hat ganz kleine Muskeln und Ärmchen, das er ganz doll draufhauen muss. Wahrscheinlich kommt genau so viel an. Das stimmt, das kann sein, ich weiß es nicht. Der Sanitäter sah auch nicht unzufrieden aus, der hat vielleicht auch einfach so Innovationen, er sagt, keine schlechte Idee eigentlich. Vielleicht kann man das so machen. Vielleicht wird einer von euch irgendwann von diesem Mädchen gerettet, von daher, ich unterstütze das auf allen Ebenen.
Wie sah die Puppe aus? Hat die Puppe so ein totes Gesicht oder weil man will die ja immer nicht zu dramatisch designen und deswegen haben die oft einfach so ein neutrales Gesicht. Wie Menschen, die auf diesen Plakaten, wo man im Flugzeug sitzt, die dann vor Feuer weglaufen und sowas, die auch meist lachen, weil man jetzt nicht diese panisch schreiende Menschen, was noch weirder wäre, halt auf diese Poster machen will, auf diese Karten, die man, diese Safety Cards. Zudessen haben die dann immer so ein sehr neutrales Gesicht oder manchmal auch einfach so laufen, aber halt vor Flammen weg. Ja, noch brenne ich nicht. Ich habe es geschafft, weg. Und meine blöde Freundin ist verbrannt. Nein, die Puppe sah sehr schockiert aus. Muss man wirklich sagen, schockiert. Direkt so ein Okay, alles klar. Augen aufgerissen. Lass uns erst mal essen gehen, einfach so. Die war wirklich so, meine Privatsphäre wurde verletzt. Die Puppe lag einfach da. Und es war auch keine Kinderpuppe so. Normalerweise kennt man dann so einen kleinen Bär. Kindergitarren, ja, aber wenn das Kind ... Ja, oder so eine kleine Schlange oder so. Kann ja nicht nur Kinder wiederbeleben, sondern wahrscheinlich auch einfach erwachsene Menschen jetzt. Das stimmt, die wird schon von Anfang an geschult. Aber ich hoffe, dass Sie es gelernt haben, weil ich habe von meinem Erste-Hilfe-Kurs nichts behalten. War auch Führerschein bei dir? Null Führerschein. Das einzige, was ich weiss noch genau, wie man mit so abgetrennten Körperteilen geht und so. Aber da würde ich mich dann einfach ... da hieß es dann so, wenn Sie sehen, dass jemand abgetrennte Körperteile hat, täuschen Sie einen Anruf vor und gehen Sie einfach weg. Genau, gehen Sie weg. Und dann gehen Sie einfach so, ah, sorry, oh, Alter, mir fällt jetzt in dem Moment ein, dass meine Mutter heute Geburtstag hat. Wie jetzt? Ja. Oh mein Gott! Happy birthday! Ihr denkt, nein, nein, ihr versteht das nicht. Wie würde das nicht verstehen? Nein, das ist sehr nett. Hä? Ich bin vorbeiratet. Leute mit Handy, kommen zur Bühne. Sehr gut, dass du davon ausgehst, dass ich die Nummer meiner Mutter auswähle. Ich kenne einfach so. Punkt eins, Punkt zwei, dass er sein Handy nicht gerade dabei hat. Was ist das sonst in seiner Tasche? Erkältung. Kleiner Funfact dazu. Du bist full of surprises. Kleiner Funfact dazu, ich war gerade auf der Toilette, hatte mein Handy nicht dabei, hatte mein, das ist der Mainzer Humor, liebe Freunde, der selber. Am Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag gehe ich heute Abend raus und lache mich kaputt.
Und wenn er noch nicht fertig ist mit seinem Witz, lache ich trotzdem schon mal auf. Ja, lieb ich. Nein, ich bin auf die Toilette gegangen und hatte mein Handy aber gerade am Ladekabel im anderen Raum. Und dann so dieser Notfallfaktor so, oh fuck, was soll ich jetzt machen, ich sitze auf dem Klo, habe kein Handy. Und dann habe ich wirklich reflexartig, ganz normal diese Packung Taschentücher rausgeholt und habe sie einfach angestarrt. Einfach so, weil das so gelernt ist von dem Mussel, einfach so, was steht hinten drauf? Nochmal ein grösser, okay, alles klar. Wie viel sind drin? Zehn Stück, okay. Moment, nur zehn Stück sind da drin? Zehn Stück sind drin, ja. Hätte ich nicht gesagt. Ich hätte zwölf getippt. Hier steht auch zum Beispiel, was Taschentücher auf Italienisch steht.
Okay.
Fatsoletti!
Die Sache ist die, das ist natürlich jetzt witzig, ha, ha, meine Mutter und so, klar, aber die checkt diese Ebene nicht, halt gar nicht so.
Das ist so, vor allem ich habe heute schon versucht, zweimal sie anzurufen, sie ist nicht rangegangen, was ein schlechtes Zeichen ist, aber auf der anderen Seite überlege ich echt gerade, wenn wir hier durch sind, ist es vielleicht echt zu spät. Fuck, ey, das ist... Nee. Ja, aber das Ding ist, das Ding ist... Weil ich hätte deine Mutter schon angerufen. Das Ding ist, ja, wer, okay, die meisten von euch wahrscheinlich schon einfach, ja, ihr könnt das nicht. Das Ding ist, sie will dann über private Sachen reden und so und das ist dann schwierig. Genau deswegen wollen wir alle, dass du deine Mutter anrufst, weil was Privates hast du zu erzählen, das will ich auch mal gerne wissen. Ich glaube, ich erfahre dann sehr viel, ich wäre gern dabei, auch wenn du es heute Abend machst, ich bin trotzdem einfach dabei, ich nehme mich daneben und grins dich an. Okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach. Okay ey, aber wir müssen so leise sein. Das ist einfach dumm. Das ist einfach Dummheit. Das sind die Momente in der Doku, wo man sich denkt, du wusstest, wie das ausgeht. Du wusstest, wie das ausgeht. Das ist wieder ein Moment, wo Dan Harmon damals Chevy Chase einrufen wurde. Genau, mit Trunken gesprochen haben. Es ist einfach so dumm, das ist der Täter am Tatort und du denkst so, warum lässt du
die Tatwaffe liegen?
Die wird gefunden, die Leute haben Technik.
Wir können es ja rausschneiden aus der Folge, die erscheint, weil es ist alles unser Geheimnis.
Ja, dann macht euch jetzt mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen gefasst auf acht Minuten
Piepton.
Wir holen Luft, piep, okay.
Rückblickt denn wir sagen, dass der Moment. Okayise. Okay, muss aber auch leise sein. Das ist so dumm einfach. Bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, bitte geh nicht ran, drei ist zu lang, niemand geht nach drei noch ran, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, hör auf jetzt! Zurzeit ist niemand, ah yes! Oder geht sie dran mit, weil sie so eine Gag-Mutter ist, zur Zeit ist telefonisch jemand
erreichbar. Ich hab Geburtstag, ich bin deine Mom. Für Geburtstagsgrüsse ist es jetzt schon zu spät. Hinterlassen Sie Ihre erbärmliche Entschuldigung nach dem Piepton. Weil so stellst du uns alle deine Mutter vor. Das Tolle ist jetzt, ich hab jetzt auf Tape, dass ich versucht hab, heute Sie anzurufen. Ja, ja, weil Sie sagst, ich sehe bei Weihnachten so, von dir kann man mein Geburtstag auch nix und du sagst, haha, ich habe da was vorbereitet, schiebst den, genau, schiebst den Fernsehwagen rein. Ja, du schiebst den Fernsehwagen rein. Bitte schön, die Tour-DVD einfach rein und dann guck mal hier. Die Tour-DVD, die wir hier aufgenommen haben, vor diesem staubigen Hintergrund. Scheiße, ey, was ... Wie, was ist jetzt los? Hey, hey, hey. Ja, das ist einfach, das Problem ist, sie hat halt viele Söhne. Da kann man manchmal auch einfach darauf hoffen, dass man untergeht in der Masse. Es klingt schon wie so ein Rätselanfang. Flor und die Mutter hat drei Söhne. Drei Söhne. Einer ruft immer um neun Uhr an. Einer ruft um neun Uhr an, einer vergisst es, einer ruft um viertel nachher. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das bei euch auch so ist, wenn ihr eurer Eltern das einzige Mal im Jahr anruft, wenn sie Geburtstag haben und die dann im... Okay, anscheinend bin ich der einzige? Okay, gut. Nur mal kurz abchecken wollen. Relatable Comedy, Florentin Will. Mein. Ich gehe einfach rein, mal gucken, wer mit dabei ist, wer Bock hat, auf diese Reise mitzugehen. Es ist eine Achterbahn, ihr könnt euch neben mich setzen oder ihr könnt daneben stehen und zuschauen. Es ist eine Wildwasserbahn, es ist eher im Genuss der Natur und der im Gebring. Und dann ruft man an und dann sagen die so, ja, der Konstantin hat ja schon angerufen und der Paul hat ja schon angerufen und man zählt nur im Sinne von, damit die einem zeigen, dass man sich schon erinnern würde, wenn man einen nicht angerufen hätte. Also das ist schon klar. Wer kennt das Phänomen? Ja, doch, guck mal, das sind einige. Das sind nämlich eher die stillen. Ich glaube, eher die stillen Leute haben so die gleichen Erfahrungen wie ich. Du bist eher so der Laute, du bist der extrovertierte, der so waaau Typ und ich bin eher so der, na okay, ganz cool. Du meinst beim Aufzeigen im Publikum? Ja. Ich würde ganz langsam so machen. Ja? Nein, du hast lange starke Arme, die sofort... Ja, ja, aber den würde ich ganz langsam hochbewegen. Und dann neben mir schon so, ach, die Frage ist vorbei. Und dann fünf Sekunden lang und dann ... Nee, nee, langsamer. Langsamer schnippen? Ja. So ganz tief. Jetzt können da nur Hunde hören. Haben wir Hunde dabei heute? Wer hat seinen Hund mitgenommen, wer hat gesagt, das musst du sehen? Ja, das ist kein Hund, das ist ein Kissen. Bei einem Auftritt wurde uns ein Hund angekündigt vorher, ein grosser Hund, der dann in der ersten Reihe sitzt. Und ich habe so Angst gehört, den wir aufgetragen, aber ich hatte so ein grosser schwarzer Bluthorn mit so roten Augen, sitzt er die ganze Zeit links und lacht halt nicht, weil natürlich nicht, weil er ist ja ein Hund. Weil der zwei Stunden lang nur ... ... versteht. Und er macht so ins Publikum, weil die im Buede Reaktionen macht. What the fuck is happening? Neuig bin ich durch Köln mit dem Auto gefahren und es saß hinten im Auto vor mir, hinter dem ich sehr lange unterwegs war, ein Hund. Und ich lieb das immer, weil die gucken ja immer hinten raus, gucken einen dann immer so an. Und ich habe es nicht gehört, weil das andere das Auto war und alle Fenster waren zu, aber er hat mich gesehen und hat angefangen zu bellen laut und das sehr lange, hinter sehr vielen Ampeln, wo wir dann hintereinander stammen. Und irgendwann hat das Herrchen so nach hinten geguckt und so und mich so angeguckt und auch so den Rückspiegel so justiert, um mich anzugucken, weil er dachte irgendwie, dass ich den Hund provoziere.
Oder sowas dachte ich dann und habe mich extra so ruhig gestellt, weil ich dachte, ich will jetzt nicht dem Typen vor mir das Gefühl geben. Ich hatte so Angst vor diesem Menschen im Auto vor mir, dass er denkt, ich provoziere seinen Hund. Ich habe erst aber auch nicht verstanden, warum der Hund mich die ganze Zeit angebellt hat. Und mein erster Gedanke war wirklich mein Gehirn, weil wenn man im im Straßenverkehr von anderen Leuten irgendwie angemacht wird oder sowas, war es bei mir immer, weil ich mein Licht nicht anhatte. Genau. Und mein erster, dann hat der Hund mich angebellt und mein erster Impuls war, das Licht zu checken, ob das Licht, und dann dachte ich mir, was für ein guter Hund das wäre, wenn er mich darauf aufmerksam macht. Er hätte immer so versucht zu... Ach so, sorry, sorry. Aber wie sahst du aus, als du versucht hast, möglichst nicht provokativ dem Hund gegenüber auszusehen? Also erstmal diese Viertel nach Zehn Stellung am... Ja? Oh, ich kann die auch nicht lesen, vielleicht auch Viertel nach Sieben. Diese Stelle, die man lernt beim Autoführerschein. Ja. Oh, das ist ein ungefährlicher Blick, oder wie? Lippen fest aneinander gepresst. Lippen aneinander gepresst, aber mit so einem leichten Grinsen geformt. Niemand, also niemand. Das sieht aggressiv, unter Hunden ist das aggressiv. Ja, wirklich aggressiv. Ich denke, der Hund war, wenn man, glaube ich, Hunden so lange in die Augen guckt, dann fühlen sie sich provoziert, glaube ich. Das kann sein.
Wenn die dann zuerst weggucken, bist du der Alpha, das ist wichtig.
Denkt der Hund, er fährt das Auto?
Nee, oder? Einfach...
Er denkt, er fährt rückwärts.
Das ist so...
Ich habe als Kind schon manchmal gedacht, ich fahre das Auto.
Ich hatte dann auch so ein kleines Lenkrad oder so mit der Hand. Ja gut, aber das hat der Hund ja nicht. Ja, aber der Hund hat ja auch keine Hände, vielleicht denkt der eher so. Das hat mit seiner Gedankenkraft, dass das Auto rückwärts fährt. Ja, weil der Hund denkt ja, immer wenn die irgendwo hinwollen, packen sie mich ins Auto. In hundert Prozent der Zellen, wo ich im Auto sass, sind wir von A nach B gekommen. Wir wollen irgendwo hinfahren, komm, komm her und ihr so, okay, alles klar, Stau, Verkehrslage ist schwierig, ich fahre ich denn. Was glaubst du, checken Hunde alles? Nein, zu nichts, glaube ich. Nein, zu nichts. Oder alles, wir wissen es nicht genau. Ich meine, kommt darauf an, es gibt manche Hunde, die können Drogen finden und andere Hunde, die können gar nichts. Also ich glaube, da gibt es eine gewisse Bandbreite, die einfach sagen so, aber haben die dann auch einen Tag, also was ist, wenn die nicht arbeiten, so Drogenhunde, können die das abschalten, können die die Arbeit im Büro lassen oder sind die dann auch, wenn die mit auf eine Party genommen werden und dann so, haha, ja, okay, Entschuldigung, ist einfach ein neugieriger Typ. Nee, die kommen dann zu ihrer Hundefamilie so nach Hause und dann sagt die Frau so, Rex, du musst die Arbeit wirklich mal bei der Arbeit lassen, du kannst dich nicht mal mit nach Hause nehmen. Weißt du, es ist einfach so, ich sehe jeden Tag, was das so leid... Ich mache gleich mal einen Kaffee. Oh ja, oh ja, ja, ja, ja, mach mir einen Kaffee, mach mir einen Kaffee, mach mir einen Kaffee. Oh, es freut mich, wie du dich freust. Klar. Du weißt, ich sehe halt auf der Arbeit immer so, wie Drogen Leben zerstören können von Menschen. Und deswegen, danke. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,, Drogenhund, okay, gut, aber stell dir mal vor, du hast einen Leichensuchhund und du bist da mit unterwegs. Wie gruselig, wenn er plötzlich anfängt zu bellen. Genau, also ich weiß nicht, Schatz, ich glaube, es ist langsam an der Zeit, dass wir auch mal meine Eltern besuchen zusammen. Wir sind jetzt seit drei Monaten zusammen und du kannst Rocco ja mitnehmen, das ist ja kein Problem. Und dann fahren wir da hin, es ist nur ein Nachmittag, wir essen ein Stück Kuchen, kein Problem. Okay, wir gehen zu deinen merkwürdigen, ich finde die gruselig, deine Eltern. Warum findest du meine Eltern gruselig? Dein Vater hat diesen merkwürdigen Blick, wenn er Auto fährt, dieses... Das liegt nicht daran, dass du ihn vielleicht provozierst manchmal. Ich schaue ihn zu lang tief in die Augen, ja. Wir haben den Blick trainiert, wie du ihn nicht anschauen sollst, okay? Okay, ja, okay, sei einfach natürlich, okay? Dingo hat er heute frei, weil er heute nicht Leichen suchen muss. Ach, du hast Urlaub heute? Mach so die Überstunden weg? Ach, das ist ja schön. Guck nicht in seine toten, vom Leben gezeichneten Augen. Ich glaube, er will auch mal schöne Dinge sehen. Okay, guten Tag, das ist also der Georg. Schön, dich mal kennenzulernen, mein Lieber. Hi. Ja, freut mich auch nicht ganz schön. Wer bist du denn? Du bist ja ein eifriger Junge. Das Dingo. Moment mal, was, Moment mal. Dingo? Freut er sich am Teppich? Dingo. Was ist denn? Oh, das ist aber der, also habt ihr nicht eine Leine da oder irgendwie sowas für was für den? Der Dingo ist eigentlich sehr gut dressiert. Dingo ist Leichenspürhund. Und was nächste Woche passiert bei Dingo der Leichenspürhund. Die sehr kurzen Folgen. Aber ich weiss auch nicht, wie es ist. Diese eine Doku mit diesem Kind, das diesem Kind, das verschwunden ist, da hatten wir so einen Leichenhund. Entschuldigung, was? Die Show mit dem Kind, das verschwunden ist. Hier, Madeleine. Road Church. Nee, Madeleine. Ah ja. Das, was du vorher gesagt hast. Ah ja. Und die haben mir so einen Leichenhund gesagt und dann haben die so gesagt, ja, der findet Leichen auch 40 Jahre noch später. Wo ich mir denke, was, 40 Jahre? Wenn du mit dem einmal durch ein Hotel gehst, wird er nie wieder kürzlich. Ja, einfach jedes Zimmer, du kommst einfach nicht voran so, ja, da auch, ja, auch in 255, 255, guten Hallo, ja, ja, nein, kein Problem, nein, Geister leben nicht so lange 40 vierzig Jahre, zwei, fünf, drei, einfach überall. Ich meine, zeig mir ein, als ob in den letzten vierzig Jahren nicht in dieser Halle mehrere Menschen gestorben sind. Rein statistisch. Rein statistisch stirbt auch heute Abend einer von euch. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben mal die Zahlen durchgerechnet und ... Wir sind nicht gut mit Zahlen oder Statistik, aber es kam plus minus eins raus. Und minus eins macht ja keinen Sinn. Nein, es sei denn, jemand wird geboren heute Abend. Und dann möchten wir sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch, ihr habt denselben Geburtstag wie meine Mutter. Wie Florintins Mutter. Wenn euch jedes Jahr anrufen, jedes Jahr. Aber was sind die Regeln Also, wie lange muss ich es nochmal probieren? Ne, du musst schon mal probieren, nochmal. Aber auch spannend, dass es die ganze Zeit nicht will, so nein, ich will es nicht, ich will es nicht und dann nach zehn Minuten, wie oft muss man es probieren? Das Ding ist, ich habe es jetzt im Kopf, das nagt die ganze Zeit, in Specht so, die ganze Zeit so, weil jetzt habe ich es gerade und ich weiß, ich verliere es wieder, weil ich hatte es den halben Tag und dann war es wieder weg. Und jetzt, ich probiere es noch einmal und dann nach der, nee, weil das ist, aber jetzt ist Tag, ist nicht jetzt, ist jetzt Tag. Warte mal, wie lange ist Tagesschau? Jetzt ist, ach so, ich dachte, jetzt ist, in Ebersberg ist jetzt Tag. Wir müssen uns jetzt mal in alte Leute reinversetzen.
Was ist gerade für eine Zeit?
20 Uhr ist Tagesschau, ne?
Du merkst an der Reaktion, dass du böse über deine Mutter redest.
Weil meine Mutter älter ist als ich?
Okay, das ist gut.
Dann haben wir ziemlich niedrige Istrophierungen.
Meinster Meinung, nicht meine.
Ein letztes Mal.
Letzte Chance, Mutter.
Wünsche ihr frohen Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag. Das findet die nicht lustig, das versteht die nicht sowas. Aber das ist nicht, werum lustig. Das ist einfach ein anderes Publikum. Schade, schade, komm noch einmal, noch einmal, noch einmal. Aber wie sehr kippt es jetzt in deinem Kopf, dass du denkst, aber vielleicht hat sie mich weniger lieb als ich sie, weil ich denke jetzt zumindest an den Geburtstag.
Zur Zeit.
Oi!
Ich bin halb froh, halb...
Zur Zeit, bin telefonisch.
Nicht erreichbar, wuhu!
Nein, wir haben es auf Band, dass ich es mehrmals versucht habe.
Genau.
Zweimal.
Das reicht.
Nicht dreimal.
Neun Jahre Schwangerschaft, zweimal anrufen, das ist die Waage.
Das ist genau. Die Waage ist gleich, das muss jetzt irgendwann auch reichen. Was soll ich denn machen? Kann er nicht wieder reinkriechen. Habt ihr so eine WhatsApp-Gruppe? Nein, überhaupt nicht, nein, null, gar nichts. Nee, aber du und deine Brüder, habt ihr euch erinnert an den Geburtstag eurer Eltern? Passiert so was? Ich hatte tatsächlich lange, wusste ich nicht, ob meine Mutter heute oder vorgestern Geburtstag hat. Und das ist immer so ein Ding. Und dann habe ich jedes Jahr meinen Bruder geschrieben, heute oder übermorgen. Und jedes Mal hat er mich korrigiert. Und deswegen mittlerweile weiß ich es. Aber das war auch der einzige Grund, mit meinem Bruder zu interagieren. Deren Geburtstag immer auch vergisst. Der hat sich mehr auf den Tag gefreut als meine Mutter. Nein, keine Ahnung. Das weiß ich, was er denkt. Sprechen die mit ihm. Aber der hat nämlich vorgestern Geburtstag und wer hat immer Geburtstag, heute du oder meine Mom? Ja, ich überlege gerade die ganze Zeit, weil ich bin so ein bisschen paranoid geworden, so was Datenschutz angeht und solche Sachen. Deswegen überlege ich die ganze Zeit, was ist der größte Humbug, den ein Fremder mit dem Geburtsdatum meiner Mutter anrichten könnte. Also wenn man sagt, jetzt hat er sich verraten, der Trottel, jetzt hat er in der Live-Show gesagt, jetzt haben wir ihn, jetzt kriegen wir ihn dran, aber eigentlich geht nicht viel. Pass auf, doch, und zwar, wenn jetzt noch die Kritikkarte geklaut wird, kann man sich als seine Mutter in Hotels anmelden beim Check-in. Okay, ja okay, gut.
Also wenn das nicht furchterregend ist, die Vorstellung. Ich meine, was man machen könnte, ist, man könnte durch die Strassen laufen an dem Tag und gucken, wo Happy Birthday gesungen wird und da durch die Adresse finden. Aber ich bin tatsächlich gerade ein bisschen paranoid. Ich weiß auch nicht so, ob das zu schlau ist, das zu erzählen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich bin tatsächlich... Ey, wir sind hier unter uns. Ja, ja, ja, nein, ich bin tatsächlich in einem, naja, sagen wir es so, nach der Berlinshow, Tag danach, ich bin abgereist, wollte abreisen, schön hier Carsharing-Auto zum Hauptbahnhof und eine super Stresssituation. Du weißt, Zug fährt in zehn Minuten, irgendwie hundert Autos hinter dir, Parkplatz finden, Scheibenwischer an, Radio auf Flamenco, es ist alles einfach stressig in deinem Gesicht. Irgendwie Leute haben irgendwie eine Mango liegen lassen im Carsharing-Auto. Allein das beschäftigt mich mental 20 Minuten. Wie du den liegen lassen konntest von vorgestern im Auto. Ja, weil wer macht, es ist so viel Aufwand, eine Mango zu kaufen und sie dann einfach zu vergessen. Das kann ich nicht einfach verstehen. Nee, das kann man nicht.
Wenn ich eine Mango kaufe...
Der hat zu viele Mangos, der Mann.
Wenn ich eine Mango kaufe, weiss ich eine Woche danach noch.
Geil, ich habe mir letzte Woche eine Mango gekauft.
Also wer kauft so viele Mangos so nebenbei...
Wow!
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiss.
Dass man die einfach vergisst.
So, will da einparken...
Das ist die grösste Fliege, die ich in meinem ganzen Leben jemals gesehen habe.
Bis wohin sieht man die... Ich kann bitte hören. Zeig mal noch mal auf, bis wohin, welche Reihe sieht man diese Riesenfliege? What the fuck? Alter, ihr habt hier gute Augen. Alle, die sich jetzt nicht gemeldet haben, sollten sich mal gehörig Gedanken machen. Warum man nicht Leichenspürhunde und nicht Leichenspür Fliegen. Stimmt, weil die sind doch eher immer an Leichen dran.
Das Problem ist, die sind halt vier Stunden nach der Ausbildung tot.
Das sind ja immer so, das sind die Ausbildung.
So, herzlichen Glückwunsch, ihr habt es geschafft.
Ihr seid die vier von vier Milliarden Fliegen pro Tag, die es geschafft haben, diese Ausbildung abzuschliessen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Dankeschön, dankeschön, es war immer mein Wunsch.
Die Rede kommt gleich, Jesus. Ach so, Entchuldige, ich bin ein bisschen nervös.
Alle vier. So, bitte. Deine Rede, the stage is yours. Ja, vielen Dank erst mal,
Dankeschön an alle, die es nicht geschafft haben, es ist eine harte Ausbildung als,
Dankeschön, Dankeschön, vielen Dank, dankeschön, dankeschön, dankeschön, es war eine lange enthaltsame Zeit, als es damals hieß, ja, drei Tage Ausbildung, das ist eine lange, lange Zeit für mich, ich habe gesagt, das lohnt sich, denn ich will Menschen helfen, ich will Leichen finden, sie nicht nur essen, sondern auch finden, und deswegen freue ich mich jetzt darauf, auf eine lange, lange erfolgreiche Karriere für euch zu arbeiten.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Tot.
Einfach nichts gewonnen.
Es ist schwierig.
Und ich glaube, das Problem ist, du kannst sie nicht an Leinen binden, fliegen.
Das wäre ich bereit, mal zu versuchen.
Ja?
Ja.
So eine ganze, wie so eine Zahnseide, die wir gleich vorstellen an diesem Dentaltagungstag. Aber das kriegt man nachher mit Zahnseide, dann machst du so einen kleinen Knoten und dann um diese Fliege drum. Da kannst du dann mit dir spazieren gehen. Das ist das coolste Haustier der Welt, weil die meisten Leute, aka alle ab Reihe acht, sehen diese Fliege nicht und sehen nur diese Leine, die irgendwas Unsichtbares in der Luft führt und du einfach so ganz normal oder halt. Wie so Wetterballons auch so kleine Lichter hat, die so rrrr. Ja genau, wie bist nicht das ein Geist? Auf jeden Fall habe ich einen Parkplatz gesucht und bin eingebogen. Ich bin so froh, dass du noch Weißwurbel gesprochen hast. Total, ich habe Angst seit dem. Parkplatz gesucht, Typ fährt hinter mir super nah ran dass du noch weiss, worüber wir gesprochen haben. Total, ich habe Angst seitdem.
Erstes Mal.
Parkplatz gesucht, Typ fährt hinter mir super nah ran, obwohl er weiss, dass ich wenden will, fährt super nah an mich ran. Ich bin eh schon super gestresst, ihr müsst euch mir vorstellen, total verschwitzt, Kopfhörer auf, irgendwie Musik viel zu laut, alles ist furchtbar. Moment. Ja, ja, ja. So, Typ fährt nah an mich ran, super nah an mich ran, ich denke schon, was ist da los und steigt sofort aus und guckt so nach vorne an sein Auto rum und sowas in der Richtung. Und dann ich erstmal so, ja, chill, ich muss erstmal einparken, irgendwie hin und her, kein Problem. Viel Handfläche. Viel Handfläche, zum Glück habe ich auch da die Zeichen gelernt, einfach chill, gleich, später, ich, jetzt einfahren, dann machen wir. Und er so, ah, okay. Jaja, einparken, bin eingeparkt, super gestresst und komme halt da hin und der sofort zeigt mir halt irgendeinen winzigen Kratzer an seinem Auto. Kurzer Einschub. Moment. Man erlebt solche Dinge in seinem Leben und danach, nächsten Tag, denkt man sich, ach, hätte ich doch, hätte ich doch, hätte ich doch, aber wir alle wissen, manchmal ist man nicht so souverän, wie man das gerne hätte. Man steht unter Druck, der Typ ist vielleicht ein bisschen grösser und stärker als man selbst, redet ein bisschen aggressiver und man ist nicht so wahnsinnig souverän. Okay, wo wir es nachspielen, wo wir es reenacten? Ja, okay. Ihr müsst dazu wissen, dass meine generelle Kommunikationsstrategie die der Unterwürfigkeit ist. Ich versuche, mich zu unterwerfen, um den anderen runter auf mein Level zu ziehen. Ja, okay. Wie aggressiv war er, hat er schon Schimpfwörter benutzt? Sehr aggressiv. Und er hatte eine Freundin, die war auch aggressiv. Die war auch aggressiv? Ja, ja. Ist die auch ausgestiegen? Ja, ja. Alle ausgestiegen. Alle ausgestiegen. Okay. Jetzt muss ich mich methodmäßig ... Also ich direkt mit Unterwürfiger ... Oh, sorry, ey, tut mir leid, ich hab's grad nicht gesehen. Ist das ... Also, ist das so scheiße, ey. Das tut mir echt leid und so. Fuck, ey. Ja, nee. Scheisse, ich hab... Okay. Hey, sorry, I... Sorry. Da ist ein Kratzer in meinem Ford Focus. Okay, ja, können wir das irgendwie klären? Da ist ein Kratzer in meinem tiefer gelegten RS Ford Focus mit der Unterbodenbeleuchtung. Okay, wie viel soll ich Ihnen zahlen, damit das aufhört, diese Situation? Das hast du nicht gesagt. Das hast du nicht Spielstopp. Das sollte man nicht sagen. Und ich weiß, ihr alle sagt, warum, warum, in dem Moment ist man halt nicht so souverän, wie man es gerne wäre. Und die Person hat sofort gesagt, lass uns mal keine Polizei involvieren, sonst kriegst du Punkte. auch und in dem moment habe ich das hinterfragt. Das klingt wie ein Euphemismus für aufs Maul, wenn er das so sagt.
Hey, wenn du die Polizei rufst, kriegst du Punkte. Ja, ich will auf gar keinen Fall Punkte. Wer will schon Punkte haben? Ja, eben. Ich meine, ich bin ein Quadrate-Typ, ich will keine Punkte. Nicht hinterfragt, überhaupt nicht hinterfragt und dann halt irgendwie, da war kein fucking Kratzer, da war gar nichts, überhaupt nichts, irgendwie so ein winziges Ding und dann einfach so, da hätte ich gesagt, ja, unterwirf ich ganz unten, hilf ich will raus, mein Zug fährt gleich, so und dann sagt die Freundin so, ja, 400 Euro. Und ich war in dem Moment nicht so souverän, wie ihr jetzt alle super toll seid und ihr wisst alles und ihr wisst genau die Kfz-Werkstattpläne, könnt ihr runterbeten, ihr wisst genau was was kostet und ihr seid schlau, war ich in dem Moment halt einfach nicht, weil ich Angst hatte, weil... Wenn du dieser Frau 400 Euro gegeben hast, verlasse ich jetzt die Bühne und das Projekt, weil wir haben eine Firma zusammen gegründet für diesen ganzen Bums, verlasse ich jetzt diese Bühne und ich entziehe dir, als CFO kann ich das, alle Passwörter und Kreditkarten unseres ach so vollen Kontos.
Ich wende mich verzweifelt an euch. Vielleicht wart ihr auch mal in einer Situation, in der ihr am nächsten Tag dachtet, das hätte ich tun können, das hätte ich machen können, das hätte ich sagen können, in dem Moment, aber nicht so. Und dann habe ich schon gesagt, das ist ein bisschen teuer.
Und dann meinte der aber sofort, ja, das ist ein Speziallack und so und das muss man alles spezial machen. Ja, Speziallack, grün Metallic. Und dann habe ich in dem Moment halt einfach, weil ich aus der Situation rauskommen wollte, weil ich Angst hatte, irrational gehandelt habe, gesagt, ja, okay. Das geht's nicht. Stopp!
Und der Anwalt ist losing it.
Das wäre so geil, wenn das die Reaktion eines Anwalts gewesen wäre.
Wenn ein Anwalt so rein ist und er sagt,
ja genau, mein Anwalt
macht den Koffer zu und geht.
Egal, ich kriege weniger als
400 Euro. So lachend.
So, und dann,
Achtung, und dann
hieß es, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich habe jetzt aber keine 400 Euro da. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Was nicht mal gelogen war. Denke ich mir. Und dann war es so, ja, okay, was passiert ist. Alle Podcast-Suppe-Geschichten greifen in ein und gesagt, ich habe nur zwei Euro vierzig in meiner Tasche. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ich habe ihn nicht da, aber ich war wie gesagt in dem irrationalen, unterwürfigen, ich will hier-Modus und habe gesagt, ich kann es Ihnen überweisen.
So, dann hat die Freundin sofort ihr Handy ausgepackt und mir ihre I-Bahn-Nummer gezeigt. Die Freundin ist mir viel zu aufmütig dafür, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht mal ihr Auto ist. Die Freundin war das Mastermind hinter diesem ganzen Ding. So, die hat diesen ganzen Plan ausgeheckt. Und dann habe ich in meiner Notizen-App diese ich diese E-Bahn abgetippt und habe drunter geschrieben 400 Euro und habe gesagt, okay, ich überweise Ihnen das. Und diese Notiz-App hat ihr gereicht? So, und dann bin ich gegangen und dann hat die Freundin, weil die als Mastermind schnell gedacht hat, gesagt, ich will ein Foto von deinem Ausweis machen. Ah, und jetzt verstehe ich auch wieder, ob du die Geschichte kommst, weil du Angst hast, weil du glaubst, man kann mit dem Ausweis ja nichts machen. Und jetzt kommt der vielleicht einzige Moment in dieser gesamten Geschichte, wo ich vielleicht eine halbrichtige Entscheidung getroffen habe. Ich habe nicht gesagt, ging ja auch mein Führerschein. Weil ich in dem Moment dachte... Ehrlich gesagt, der Anwalt ist wieder schockiert. Der Anwalt ist wieder rauch. Er war kurz wieder drin. Der Ersatzanwalt geht. Weil ich mir in dem Moment dachte, auf meinem Führerschein steht nicht meine Adresse drauf. So. Ja, okay. Die Menge kippt langsam. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und es gibt keine Chance, Florentin Will zu erreichen. So. Wenn man Florentin Will googelt, keine Chance herauszufinden, wer das und wer der Mensch ist. Es ist kein Problem, den Geburtstag und meine Mutter herauszufinden und mir das Leben zur fucking Hölle zu machen. Weil diese Freundin wird jedes Jahr eine Mutter zum Geburtstag anrufen. Vor mir. Und da darf ich mir Weihnachten was anhören.
So, und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, wir haben ein Foto von meinem Führerschein gemacht und dann bin ich gegangen.
Und dann saß ich im Zug, hatte das Formular des Online-Bankings offen, hatte die Bankleitzahl da und dann kam langsam mein Selbstwertgefühl zurück, das ich davor habe vermissen lassen. Es kam zu spät, es kam zu spät, aber es kam. Denn wir Podcast-Unfrohörer, wir lieben Selbstwertgefühl. Alle sind erleichtert, denn eine Schwall Erleichterung geht durch den Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag. Ja, es kam zurück und ich dachte mir, ich bin weich, unterwürfig und schwach. Aber das lasse ich mir nicht gefallen. Ich überweise denen gar nichts. So, und jetzt ist irgendwo da draußen ein wütender, kräftiger Mann mit einer schlauen Freundin, die meinen Namen haben und den Ort, an dem mein Führerschein ausgestellt wurde, an dem ich aber nicht mehr wohne. Und jetzt, und das ist jetzt eine Woche her, und ich mache mir seit einer Woche Gedanken, wann kriege ich aufs Maul, wann ist der Tag, an dem ich aus meiner Tür rausgehe und einfach BAP von diesem Typen ein, warum hast du mir das Geld nicht. Das erklärt eine Instagram-Nachricht, die ich bekommen habe, und hier ist er! Nein, nein, ich wollte überweisen! Und beide kommen dann wieder so an.
Und ich dachte mir auch so, ja, okay, der hat jetzt vielleicht nicht meine Adresse oder alles, aber er hat meinen Namen. Und deine Würde vor allem. Meine Führerscheinklasse. Meine Führerscheinklasse. Und ein Bild von mir, als ich 16 war. Sehilfe ist zu tragen. Also Druckmittel sind vorhanden.
Und ich denke mir, das Mindeste, was ja passieren kann, ist, dass er mich googelt und mich auf Instagram findet und mir zumindest mal schreibt, hey, wo ist mein Geld? Nicht passiert, gar nichts passiert. Nichts. Und mittlerweile fühle ich mich eigentlich okay. Nur, bis zu dem Moment, als ich den Geburtstag meiner Mutter veröffentlicht habe, weil es kann sein, dass diese Person diesen Podcast hört, oder heute hier an Business! Ich weiss es nicht, ich weiss wirklich nicht, weil das sind ja Leute, die, also vor allem würdest du Personen einfach googeln, wenn du sie finden willst oder was, du würdest ja nicht damit rechnen und ich habe echt überlegt, was kann passieren, was kann passieren? Ich würde sie sofort googeln, also auch no chance, dass es nicht passiert ist, dass sie Florentin Will in Leerzeichen, Anführungszeichen bei Google eingegeben haben und dann nach den ersten drei Buchstaben gemerkt haben, ah okay, es gibt einen Florentin Will und der ist auch noch berühmt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, und ich bin, ich habe mir das Gefühl, ich muss ein bisschen mein Ansehen wiederherstellen, weil ich das jetzt nicht so, Ich glaube, ich war an einem Punkt noch clever. Weil ich dachte mir, was ist ... Zwei Führerschein. Das ist nicht so super klug, das jetzt so zu sagen, weil das ist mein Backup-Plan. Weil ich dachte mir, das ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, ist, dass der Typ mir irgendwo auflauert und mich zusammenschlagen will und sagen, wo ist mein Geld. Und dafür habe ich ein Backup, weil ich habe. Und jetzt käme der Moment im Film, wo wir nochmal so in der Zeit stückweise zurückspringen und wir mit der Ocean's Eleven Musik so sehen, im Zug, ich zu Hause, und wir sehen den Moment, wo ich diese Kontonummer eintippe, und dann sehen wir einen anderen Moment, wo ich diese Kontonummer um eine Zahl verändere,
so dass, wenn die Person kommt und mich zusammenschlagen will, ich sagen kann, gut, dass Sie da sind,
ich habe versucht, Ihnen Geld zu überweisen, aber aus irgendeinem Grund hat das nicht funktioniert,
lassen Sie uns nochmal bitte die Ibans abgleichen und dann käme heraus, ja tatsächlich, die stimmt nicht, guter Grund, ich schlag ihm nicht aufs Maul. Das ist zumindest mein Plan. Und ich finde den nicht so schlecht unter den Umständen. Ich finde es interessant, wie du das unterbekommen willst, in Faust fliegt hin zu, stopp, folgende Sachen. Und ich bin sogar so weit gegangen, dass ich in dem Online-Banking-Formular die falsche I-Bahn eingetippt habe. Und dann ist ja auch immer so das Ding, du musst ja bei dem Bankkonto, bei dem Formular den Namen des Empfängers eingeben. Ja, habe ich ja nicht. Aber das ist ein verpflichtendes Feld. Okay, war die Freundin so ein Mastermind. Und jetzt denke ich mir, was gebe ich dir ein? Da habe ich einfach eingeben, freundlicher BMW-Fahrer betreffend Kratzer. Ich wusste es. Wir alle haben uns den BMW vorgestellt, oder? Ja, ja, ja. Und dann habe ich das sogar versucht und dann hat die Webseite gesagt, ungültige I-Bahn. Davon habe ich einen Screenshot gemacht, damit ich im Nachhinein sagen kann, während die Faust mit Schallgeschwindigkeit auf mich zufliegt. Wieso Pfefferspray holst du diesen Screenshot raus und er sagt ... Ja, wir können es ja mal machen. Du bist der Typ und parkst jetzt mit deinem Auto neben mir. Ich laufe einfach so, komme einfach nach dieser Show vielleicht, laufe ich zu meinem Hotel. Hey! Oh, oh, Sie sind's, ich habe versucht, das Geld zu überweisen, aber die I-Bahn war falsch, leider. Ich hab hier... Ich hab hier den Zwieschott. Haha, weiche, der Bon! Weiche! Das geht, ich hab das ausgerechnet mit der Zeit, das geht. Es scheint zu gehen. Aber tatsächlich, also ich meine, ich bin wirklich ein schwacher Typ, der keine Erfahrung mit Gewalt hat und nichts. Und allein, ich habe wirklich ein paar Tage Angst gehabt. Wer weiss denn, wer das ist, vielleicht ist das irgendein Gangster-Typ. Ich kann dir, ich lache nicht so bescheuert, ich kann dir helfen. Naja, aber du willst mich beschützen rund um die Uhr oder was?
Ja.
Es ist nett, also so... Komm.
Nee, nee, es ist wirklich nett.
Es ist nicht rund um die Uhr, aber so elf bis achtzehn Uhr würde ich dich beschützen im Sinne von, ich bin einen Anruf entfernt. Ja, du, aus dem Krankenhaus würde ich dich sofort anrufen, das ist klar. Ja, aber ich hab mal gedacht, weil wir hatten mal so einen crazy big ass Türsteher, damals, als wir noch beim Neo-Magazin gearbeitet haben, und der hat mir immer gesagt, Riesenschrank und so, und mit Sicherheit hat er auch Waffen und so, keine Ahnung, aber er hat gesagt, ich boxe dich aus allem raus, wenn du mal irgendwas kommst, ruf mich einfach an, hier ist meine Nummer, und ich dachte mir so, wie sieht dieses Szenario aus, wo ich angegriffen werde und dann sage, ganz kurz. Ich kenne da jemanden, weil das hat keine Chance. Also entweder der geht die ganze Zeit mit mir durch Köln. Aber ich meine, wenn es eine Situation gibt, dann jetzt die. Ich würde sagen, wir rufen den Herrn mal an, der mir Personenschutz geben soll. Ich brauche ab jetzt Personenschutz. Aber ab wann hast du überlegt, die Polizei anzurufen? Zu keinem Zeitpunkt. I ain't no snitch. Sorry, ein bisschen das Gesetz der Straße kenne ich. Wo geht die Linie? Ja, was soll ich denn der Polizei? Ich habe super Angst und bin ein verweichlichtes Idiotkind, aber ich traue mich nicht, die Polizei anzurufen, weil ich auch Angst davor anrufe. Aber wenn die eine Mailadresse auf ihrer Website stehen haben, bin ich der Erste, der denen schreibt. Ja, was soll ich in der Polizei sagen? Ich habe die Vermutung, dass ich betrogen wurde von einem fremden Mann in einer anderen Stadt. Dann sagt die Polizei, okay, hol das SEK, let's fucking go. Aber dass die dir den Namen nicht gegeben haben, ist ja hilarious. Ja, die haben mir gar nichts gegeben. Ja, aber dann bist du ja fein raus. Da brauchst du nicht gross Screenshots machen oder sowas. Du kannst einfach sagen, ich habe meinen Namen nicht gegeben. Ich kann euch nichts überweisen. Du drobes Arsch. Man kann schon über... Du brauchst den Namen nicht, um zu überweisen. Du kannst schon überweisen. Doch, man braucht den Namen, um zu überweisen. Nein, das Fade... Nein, man muss das Fade schon...
Nein, nein, stopp, man muss das Fade schon...
Haben wir irgendwelche Bankleute hier oder so?
Ja, Bankleute.
Ah, okay, wir haben tatsächlich jemanden...
Das Pärchen, beide wissen Bescheid, beide kennen sich aus.
Sorry, Entschuldigung, wir müssen dich kurz hören.
Also es wird nicht überprüft, ob es stimmt, aber man kann auch...
Man kann auch einen anderen Namen eintragen und dann...
Okay, also der Name ist egal.
Der Name ist egal, also habe ich gewonnen. Nein, nein, nein, also hast du wieder das Problem. Ich nehme die Treppe, ich bin einfach nicht so sportlich. Scheiße, ey. Aber hast du dir kurz überlegt, was du machst in der Zeit der restlichen Lebenszeit, die dir bleibt komm mal her komm jetzt bitte her hast du dir überlegt wie wie bringst du diese zeit ist noch rum du hast noch gute drei tage zu leben ich habe mir liegt so ich war dem tod noch nie so nah sehr behütetes leben ich dachte mir ich habe vielleicht noch diese woche zu leben das einzige was ich noch erleben möchte und du hast überlegt hierher zu kommenheinland-Pfalz-Tag. Genau, ich habe gesagt, ich möchte den Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag noch erleben. Da lerne ich, wie ich mich zur Not selbst wiederbeleben könnte. Falls der Typ mir einfach die Luftröhre einschlägt, liege ich da und kann mich versuchen, selber wiederzubeleben. Hat das schon mal jemand gemacht? Nein, offensichtlich nicht. Das ist echt ... Finde ich schon witzig eigentlich. Völlig übertrieben, wenn jemand hinfällt und dann versucht, sich selber wiederzubeleben. Einfach so alles nicht so schlimm. Und dabei merkt, ah ja, ich lebe noch. Ja, aber ich weiß, wisst ihr, nach einer Zeit, man gewöhnt sich an die Angst. Ich bin ein verfolgter Mann, ich bin Outlaw, mein Kopf steht wahrscheinlich in vielen Gangsterhöhlen mittlerweile an oberster Priorität, aber ich habe gelernt, damit zu leben. Es ist Teil von mir geworden und ich habe auch ein Video zur Selbstverteidigung angeguckt. Es ist einfach mal... Okay, okay, okay, spannend. Haha, ich bin kurz...
YouTube, ich dachte...
Selbstverteidigung, Pamela Reif, zack. Es ist einfach was... Okay, okay, okay, spannend. War ich mir kurz...
YouTube.
Selbstverteidigung, Pamelerei, zack.
Das ist der Worst Case, der Worst Case ist, der Typ kommt und haut mir direkt ins Gesicht,
bevor ich diese Story mit dem Screenshot sagen kann, was mache ich dann.
Und ich habe mir Selbstverteidigung für Anfänger angeguckt und da heißt es,
sollten Sie in einer Gefahrensituation sein, rennen Sie so schnell es geht weg. Und das ist mein Plan. Und dann wenn die Person, die dich verfolgt, schneller ist als du? Kein Plan B. Video war vorbei, Abspann. Holen Sie den, ja dann ganz noch viel so Abonnier und hol die Glocke oder so. Abonnier und so viel so Windows Movie Maker Gedöns. Es ist ja, ich habe ja, sag ich mal, es ist ja so, ich habe den Orangengürtel in Karate, es ist ja nicht. Also wenn, ich weiss genau, wenn der kommt, kann ich genau so blockieren, in jeder anderen Situation gebe ich auf. Es ist schwierig, es ist schwierig. Ja okay, aber okay, das ist ja interessant. Aber hast du jetzt überlegt, dass du, also wie viel ausgebildet bist du jetzt durch diese Videos? Ich bin bereit, ich bin bereit. Ich habe mir wirklich überlegt, was ist das, dann würde ich versuchen, Entschuldigung, ich wollte ihn noch überweisen. Also du bist nicht weiter, du bist immer noch nicht. Ich bin nicht wirklich weiter, aber ich würde halt einfach versuchen, in der Hüfte geschmeidigt zu bleiben und möglichst versuchen, ein Fängst. Ich würde mich verrückt stellen. Ich würde meine Hose runterziehen und sagen, bla bla Barbara Honig. Ja, es ist wirklich eine gute Möglichkeit. Und dann würde er sagen, was? Und die Freundin wäre verwirrt auch. Aber ich habe mir eine ähnliche Strategie überlegt. Ich dachte, wenn der andere super aggressiv auftaucht, dann einfach so ganz entspannt oder locker und einfach so eine dumme Frage stellen, so was ist ihr Telefonanbieter oder irgendwie so, oder irgendwie irgend so was dummes, weil ich glaube, der ist es halt gewohnt, auf Gewalt mit Gewalt beantwortet zu werden, dass man sofort geht, aber wenn man das überhaupt nicht macht, das war aber mein ganzer Plan von der ganzen Geschichte, dass es überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, dass ich unteraggressiv reingehe, vielleicht klappt es dann trotzdem nicht. Es war furchtbar. Aber was ich spannend finde, ist, weil es gibt ja Hypnotiseure, Hypnotiseurinnen, die immer wieder in so Talkshows auftreten und so, und da sitzen da Leute auch bei Anne Will, nicht jetzt, aber stellen wir uns doch vor, bei Anne Will, sie ist dann da. Ist das eine Kritik an der Redaktion von Anne Will, dass sie, wie du immer vers eine Scheiss-Hypnose-Kritik mit einzuflechten. Du willst mehr die Söhre in der Herzen sein. Es war die dürfste Talkshow, die ich mir da aussah. Aber gut, Anne Will sitzt Bosbach und sagt, ich glaube nicht an so einen Scheiss. Und Kevin Kühnert sagt, nee, ich auch nicht. Und dann hypnotisiert er die aber mit so, keine Ahnung, bam, bam, bam, sie fallen in Schlaf. Ja. So, und Kevin Kühnert sitzt dann da und dann lesen die die Gedanken von Kevin Kühnert zum Beispiel jetzt. Ja, was er wirklich denkt. Talkshows gibt es ja. Aber das ist doch auch gut, weil bei Politikern sagt man immer, ja der lügt, der macht das nicht, weil er im Wahlkampf ankündigt. Lügendetektor. Wo ist der erste politische Kandidat, der sagt, ich werde die Steuern senken, hypnotisieren Sie mich gerne und fragen Sie mich nochmal, ich werde es auch dann sagen. Ich bin so ehrlich, ich habe keine Angst, hypnotisiert zu werden. Okay, setzen Sie sich hin. Okay, alles klar. Ich sage, Steuern runter auf alles. Okay, Will, ich glaube, das will auch niemand, weil dann funktioniert das System nicht mehr, aber ich bin nur Hypnotisier. Ich habe jetzt nur Hypnose gelernt. Vielen Dank, Frau Will, übrigens für die Einladung, das freut mich sehr.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt mit politischen Kontrahenten gerechnet, aber nette Runde, wir haben schon Glöhrenfeuerspucker und Hypnotiseur.
Mir fällt jetzt erst auf, dass ihr den gleichen Nachnamen habt.
Das ist okay.
Weil ich habe erst an deine Mutter gedacht.
Okay.
Aber ich denke, so, der lag auf der Strasse.
Ich liege auch bald auf der Strasse, wenn der Typ mich findet.
Schliessen Sie bitte die Augen und atmen Sie langsam ein und wieder aus.
Und atmen Sie langsam wieder ein und wieder aus.
Und dann sehen Sie in der Ferne eine Tür.
Die Augen sind zu. Ja.
Mit geschlossenen Augen in der Ferne.
Und jetzt Und dann sehen Sie in der Ferne eine Tür. Die Augen sind zu. Ja. Mit geschlossenen Augen in der Ferne. Und Sie sehen eine Tür in der Ferne, eine helle Tür. Da gehen Sie durch, und wenn Sie durchgehen, dann sind Sie hypnotisiert. Sie gehen durch die Tür, Sie gehen durch die Tür und Sie gehen durch die Tür. Ach so, ich hätte vorher so ein Wort sagen müssen, mit dem man nicht wieder aufbaut, glaube ich.
Aber, ja, we cross that bridge when we get there.
Okay, wenn Sie mich hören, dann sagen Sie auf die Frage Ja.
Hören Sie mich?
Ist ja für alle Beteiligten, jetzt bin ich besser, wenn Sie ... Sorry, Frau Will, Frau Will, ich hab das unter Kontrolle. Ich hab's unter Kontrolle. Ich hab's unter Kontrolle. Ich hab's unter Kontrolle. Frau Will, wirklich, wenn Sie mich jetzt nicht ausreden lassen und das machen lassen, dann ... So. Fuck, kann irgendwer, kann irgendwer ... Okay. Kommen wir nun zu den Wahlauszählungen der Bundeskanzlerwahl. Mit über 80 Prozent der Stimmen gewinnt Fridolin Karoset, der erste Kandidat. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sie haben die Wahl gewonnen! Und der ging als erfolgreichster Bundeskanzler in die Geschichte Deutschlands ein.
Der hat mal was gemacht. Ja, der hat, ich sag mal, das ist einer wie ich, ich schlaf auch. Genau solche Leute brauchen wir in der Politik. Von Olaf Scholz habe ich auch noch nie mehr gehört. Ich sag dir, wir werden noch politisch, ich weißiss auch nicht, wir werden noch ein politischer Podcast.
Ach ja, ich habe, aber ich weiss nicht, irgendwie habe ich, ich habe das, hier fühle ich mich sicher.
Ich weiss nicht, ich glaube, wenn der Typ jetzt auf den Lüste gehen würde.
Ja, weil du sehr viele Arbeitsplätze hast.
Ja, ich glaube, wer von euch würde mich verteidigen, wenn ich, ja, okay.
Wer von euch würde für mich sterben?
Aber es haben so viele, Okay, eine Person, okay.
Eine Person.
Aber sehr ehrlich von allen dann sagt, das nicht.
Sogar geht es lieber dann doch nicht.
Das nicht.
Ich will noch den nächsten Rheinland-Pfalz-Tage erleben.
So nicht.
Alle sehr ehrlich.
Ja, aber vor allem, ich denke immer wieder über diese Freundin nach.
Dieser Masterplan, der wahrscheinlich entstanden ist, zwischen Aussteigen, weil das hat lächerlich lange gedauert, bis ich da noch eingeparkt bin und dann zu dem gegangen bin, hat die in der Zeit gesagt, hey, wir sagen dem jetzt, ich sag 400 Euro. Das ist eine Chance für uns, okay? Okay, schau den Typ an, Mann. Der schwitzt, der ist weich, der hat irgendwie Kopfhörer auf. Ich verfrügel den, ich verfrügel den. Nein, nein, nein, hey, hey, hey, Schatz, pass auf. Okay, okay, okay. Ich habe dir gestern Abend versprochen, dass ich mehr auf dich höre. Ja, okay. Und es wird sich für uns beide auszahlen. Okay, was ist der Plan? Du verprügelst ihn jetzt noch nicht. Okay, okay. Sondern wir sagen ihm einfach, er hat einen Kratzer in das Auto gefahren. Aber hat der Kratzer in mein Auto gefahren? Nein, hey, hey, der hat überhaupt nichts gemacht. Der hat überhaupt nichts gemacht. Der ist perfekt eingeparkt, der hat gar nichts gemacht, der hört einen guten Podcast. Okay, er ist nicht sehr gut eingepackt. Wir sollten ihn loben, dass er so gut eingepackt ist. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, wir tun so, als hätte er einen Kratzer reingefahren. Und ich sage dann, das ist ein teurer Lack für 400 Euro. Aber der hat nur maximal 3,80 Euro gekostet, der Lack. Das muss der ja aber nicht wissen, Schatz. Hm? Okay? Lass mich reden. Jenny, du bist das Beste, was mir passiert ist. Das ist nett. Danke, das ist nett von dir. Ich liebe dich so sehr. Wirklich. Weil letztes Jahr bin ich von den Drogen runtergekommen und ich wusste nicht mehr... Okay, okay. Ich wusste wirklich nicht mehr... Schatz, können wir das besprechen, wenn wir zu Hause sind heute? Und ich habe an den Momenten gedacht, ich weiß nicht mehr, warum in meinem Leben. Und ich weiß nicht, weil ich kann nicht zu meinen Eltern zurück, weil du weißt, dass sie damals bei diesem furchtbaren Autounfall gestorben sind.
Und dass das das Auto ist von meinem Vater, was ich lange restauriert habe und wo ich so viel Arbeit.
Bau das in die Rolle ein, dieses Auto ist dir wahnsinnig wichtig, du willst, dass es heil bleibt. Jeder Kratzer in dem Auto ist auch ein Kratzer auf der Seele.
Ich konnte dir nicht folgen, aber ich glaube, das ist recht.
Lass mich einfach reden, lass mich einfach reden. Das ist mir nämlich auch später aufgefallen, ich hab den gar nicht berührt. Ja, hä? Aber in dem Moment wäre das mir nie eingefallen. Ich gehe da hin und der Typ sofort den hier und sagt, ja, das ist ein teurer Lack. Und er ist bei C in der Argumentationsreihe und ich würde würde nicht sagen, so... Man traut sich nicht, bei Null einzusteigen. Ja, aber ich würde sagen, Moment mal, es ist überhaupt nichts passiert. Weil ich, wirklich unter dem Stress, da steigt man sofort bei dem ein. Erst als ich zum Bahnhof gelaufen bin, der mich hatte, dachte, das ist überhaupt nichts passiert. Und ich habe den Foto von meinem Führerschein gegeben. Ja. Es ist einfach wahnsinnig dumm. Ich verstehe das, er ist nur so eingestiegen, es ist fast unangenehmer zu sagen, ich habe dich gar nicht berührt. Ja. Du bist schon vor Gericht gezerrt worden. Ja, genau. Und es ist fast, wenn jetzt ... Ja, und im Gefängnis vorm Galgen fällt mir ein, es gab überhaupt keine Konvision. Aber ich wäre da auch so anfällig für, weil es gibt diese Confession-Tapes auf Netflix auch, so eine ganze Dokureihe darüber, wie Leute zu gewissen Geständnissen gezwungen werden. Hundertprozentig. Und ich bin so ein leichtes Opfer. Ich würde es sofort sagen. Sag mir das dreimal, dass ich das so gesagt habe. Und ja, habe ich es so gesagt. Ja, erst eine Woche später würde ich sagen, ich war da auf einer Bühne vor fünf Jahren. Ich kann das gar nicht gewesen sein. Da sitzt ihr schon im Gefängnis. Das ist wirklich schrecklich. Aber ich weiss nicht, also ich fände es auch geil, wenn der Typ das jetzt hören würde und den nächsten Masterplan spinnt. Wie geht das jetzt weiter, was passiert jetzt? Also ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden auf jeden Fall, aus dem Krankenhaus oder aus freier Laufbahn. Aber nehmen wir dann noch auf? Wir müssen noch auf, wenn du im Krankenhaus bist. Wir haben dann halt nur so ein konstantes Bip. Ja, ist halt nervig, ne? Und wenn du dich aufregst über mich, dann ,,Biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, biep, Weil ich glaube, das würde helfen, glaube ich, um einen Streit zu schlichten. Ja, aber ... Wenn man immer merken würde, wenn der andere sich aufregt. Ja, genau, wie bei den Sims, wenn darüber so Regungen sind, so wenn du irgendeinen Schwachsinn wieder erzählst, und dann habe ich so ein grosses rotes Minus über meinem Kopf. Du kannst ja ab jetzt ... Ich mag dich jetzt weniger. Du kannst ja ab jetzt immer, wenn du dich aufregst, die Hand heben, damit ich weiss, damit ich einfach direkt Feedback bekomme. Okay, alles klar. Aber ich hebe auf die Hand in Gesprächen. Du bist sehr höflich. Sehr höflich. Ja, selbst im Zweifelsgespräch. Soll ich Ihnen sagen? Ja, Stefan? Achso, ich bin nur wütend. Achso, alles klar. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Okay, alles klar. Vielen Dank für die Wortmeldung, Stefan. Dankeschön. Ansonsten, wir sind natürlich angewiesen auf Feedback von allen Zahnärzteninnen und Zahnärzten hier, die hier sagen. Und muss Bohren so wehtun. Unser Team hat lange geforscht und sagt, ja, muss es. Auch einfach, weil es Spaß macht. Hast du deine Weisheitssinn rausbekommen schon? Ja, weg damit. Bei mir sind die nämlich auch raus und alle vier auf einmal bekommen, voll Narkose und es war fantastisch. Mir haben die die durch die Wange rausgenommen. Ah, wirklich? In die Wange haben die ein Loch reingeschnitten, die haben gesagt, das geht schneller, haben die in die Wange ein Loch reingeschnitten und dann einfach rein mit der ganzen Hand tatsächlich, mit der ganzen Hand durch und dann rein. Das ist eine geile Origin-Story für einen Lame-Joker-Film, weil die sich immer andere... How did I get that scar, sir? Let me tell you a story. Ein sehr billiger Zahnarzt. Why so serious? Oder er sagt nicht, why so serious, sondern ... Weißt du, wie die Snartman entstanden sind? Wie heißt die Freundin nochmal? Jenny. Von Batman? Achso, ich dachte jetzt aus der Geschichte. Freundin von Batman? Was weiss ich? Die Frau von Batman. Harlequin oder keine Ahnung, Batman hat doch keine Frau, Batman ist doch der Einzel. Rachel. Batman hat eine Frau? Naja, ein Love Interest, right? Was? Ich bin erschüttert. Welche Rückfragen kommen, ich war nicht auf Rückfragen gefasst. Batman hat keine Frau. Doch, naja, Love Interest. Nicht jeder hat eine Frau, Winnie Pooh hat auch keine Frau. Kannst du sagen, wie er ist die Freundin von Winnie-Pooh? So, der Typ ist Single und er ist glücklich und das ist okay. Ja, ist ja okay. Ja, dagegen sage ich ja gar nicht. Ihr wisst genau, dass ihr nicht glücklich seid, ihr braucht es nicht zu klatschen, okay? Erbärmlich. Rachel, weißt du, wie diese Narben entstanden sind? Wie? Naja, es war eine lange Prozedur, also die dachten, dass sie besser an meine Weisheit, an meine Achter kommen. Ich weiss nicht, ob du weiss, dass es Achter sind, weiterzählen, und dann mussten die sich aufschneiden, die Wange, und dann sind die da rangegangen. Ja. Und die haben das dann nicht zugenäht wieder? Nein. Und weisst du, wie wir die Zanas Praxis gehört hat? Wayne Enterprise. Wow. Und das Publikum so, what the fuck is happening Niemand braucht mehr diese Filme. Und deswegen nennen sie dich den Pac-Man? Ja, Crossover. It's a crossover. Nee, ich fände es besser, wenn ihr mich Joker nennt. Mit Jesus vielleicht Crossover? Aber da müssen die Franchise-Rechte erst mal ein bisschen öffnen. Ja, das stimmt.
Disney hat jetzt die Bibel gekauft.
Die Rechte, ja genau.
Wir müssen erst zu den Rechteinhabern von der Bibel gehen.
Einfach irgendwie so.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Weil die Arche-Noah-Story kann man doch bestimmt geiler erzählen, so Marvel-esken Superhelden-Megaspektakel.
Ja?
Weit ich nicht.
Ja, oder halt als Porno, so der Arche-Noah-Porno. Träge ich mir auch. Hast du schon mal sowas über ihr das eingegeben bei Porn? Ich bin ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, oder halt als Porno, so der Arche-Noah-Porno. Krieg ich mir auch. Hast du mal sowas über jedes Eingegeben bei Porn? Arche-Noah. Na klar. Wie alle kennen es, man hat eine gewisse Fantasie im Kopf, die so präzise ist, dass man sich denkt, das ist jetzt so eine präzise Googlesuche, die kann mir auch nicht vorgeworfen werden, weil das kann man nur als, ich wollte mal gucken, ob es das überhaupt gibt, wenn du einfach Arche-Noah-Porn eingibst. Aber haben Sie denn zwei Giraffen oder zwei Giraffen von jeder Giraffensorte mitgenommen? Ne, zwei Giraffen. Ich glaube, alle Sorten kamen danach erst. Und die bestafrikanischen Giraffensorte, fuck, warum nicht uns? Ja, gute Frage. Vor allem, also ich hätte als Noah auch keine Ahnung von Tieren gehabt und hätte einfach zwei Weibchen oder zwei Männchen geholt. Genau. Und dann einfach ich so, na, und los geht's. Das ist bei den Einhörnern passiert. Und die Giraffen so, das ist, also wir haben unseren Spaß, verstehe uns nicht falsch, wir sind alleine auf einem Schiff, ja, wir kommen klar, aber kein Nachwuchs. Erst bei den Einhörnern passiert, deswegen gibt es nicht mehr. Ja, das stimmt, genau, da waren es dann zwei von der selben Geschichte, ja, das ist schwierig, so sind die gestorben. It's bad, bad man. Ach ja, ist Eichenoa die beste Geschichte, ausserdem, ich weiß es nicht. Was ist denn die coolste Geschichte, diese ganzen Plagen? Ich meine, vor allem, ich finde, der brennende Busch ist geil, oder ich finde vor allem die unterrepräsentiertesten... Nicht gut? Und der Busch ist gut. Ach so, okay, Leute, ich sage es selber nicht. Leute, meine Mutter hört zu, okay? Ich schicke ihr diese ganze Stunde als Nachricht. Aber auch gut, wenn Leute dabei plötzlich sehr viel Meinung haben und so Sachen reinrufen. Vor allem, brennender Busch. Vor allem, wenn man mal die Bibel liest, Jesus ist nicht im Ansatz die coolste Figur. Warum ist der der krasseste Typ, warum hat der die meisten Sammelkarten? Was ist denn zum Beispiel, Idee, den vier fucking Reitern der Apokalypse? Warum wurde um die nicht mehr Religion gebaut, wenn man einfach sagt, vier fucking coole Reiter, die einfach alles beenden? So Suicide Squad mässig. Sind die noch zusammen eigentlich oder haben die sich getrennt? Haben die irgendwann nach dem ersten Buch gesagt, so eine Pressekonferenz und einfach gesagt, Hunger, ich will mit dir nichts mehr zu tun haben. Hunger, Krieg, Seuche, nicht schnell genug auf Textnachrichten antworten, ich weiss es nicht, was ist die vierte, Florentin, die vierte Todsünde. Ne, das ist eine fünf, du hast es nicht gelernt. Es sind fünf? Nein, du hast jetzt eine fünf bekommen, weil du konntest mir nur drei nennen, ich bin offensichtlich ein Religionslehrer, okay, du hast es mal wieder verkackt. Sorry, dass ich so wütend bin. Entschuldigung, ich bin so selten im Unterricht, dass ich nicht mehr weiss, wer sie sind, ehrlich gesagt. Wer mir die Noten... Ja, vielleicht, wenn sie häufiger kommen wären, sieht sie jetzt auch, dann hätten sie diese fünf bekommen. Warum sind sie so gross? Warum sind sie grösser als die anderen Kinder? Weil ich Religionslehrer bin, Gott hat mich lieber als euch. Deswegen, da habe ich mehr erwachsen. Aber das müsste mal so der Vatikan, der Papst gibt ja immer so Sachen raus, so Vatikan ist Papst ist jetzt unfehlbar oder doch nicht unfehlbar oder das darf man jetzt und das nicht und der einfach mal sagt, die vier apokalyptischen Reiter sind nicht mehr zusammen, die haben sich getrennt. Einfach so, jetzt wir nehmen einfach diese diese Bibi-Welle mit und sagen, der Vatikan sagt einfach
im Nachhinein noch, oh, übrigens,
Tod hat sich abgekapselt, weil Krieg die
Bandkasse geklaut hat.
Und Gandalf war schwul.
Jetzt schmeißen wir alles
noch rein. Und Winnie-Pooh hatte
aus gutem Grund keine Freundin. Ja, alles klar.
Ciao, mach's gut, ihr könnt es einfach
droppen. Ich habe gemerkt, viel Schmerz bei Bibi
war gerade im Raum, oder? Hat jemand Redebedarf? Hat jemand Redebedarf? Gar niemand? Okay. Noch nicht so weit. Wir sind noch in der Leugnungsphase mit Bibi. Bibi hat sich von ihrem Freund anscheinend getrennt, das ist ein grosses Thema. Das habe ich auch gelesen. Ja, es ist gerade ein Thema. Schade, wenn ihr das jetzt so erfahren müsst, wenn ihr das jetzt so in diesem Setting erfahren müsst. Wer ist ernsthaft entsetzt gerade? Nein, komm, gar niemand, das glaube ich euch nicht.
Ich war ein bisschen entsetzt, aber du bist eher in dieser YouTube-Bubble drin.
Wie hat man das aufgefasst bei euch?
Sehr, sehr schön.
Wir schalten in die YouTube-Bubble.
Claudin, wie hat man das aufgefasst bei euch?
Ich müsste erst mal so die Kamera anmachen, so wacke.
Du hast auch so einen grossen Pömpel, weil immer ein Shitstorm tobt. Ja, genau. Naja, es ist natürlich schwer, die haben immer die Videos zusammen gemacht, aber jetzt können die beiden natürlich noch mal neu ihre Karriere beginnen und noch mal sagen, so ja, ich lade mir Tinder runter, noch mal von vorne. Weil das ist ja so eine Plotline bei den YouTubern, das ist ja auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht alles echt. Cool fand ich auch die Fans, die gesagt haben, das ist bestimmt ein Prank. Und das ist eigentlich geil, wenn du als YouTuber so sehr für Pranks bekannt bist, dass alles, was du machst, die Leute erstmal denken, ja, das ist ein Prank. Das ist ein Problem auch. Bevor Julienko würde die Bank überfallen und er sagt, ich schiesse, wenn sie mir das Geld nicht geben. Wo ist die Kamera, wo ist die Kamera? Abonniert, Leute. Aber jetzt auch so, wenn jetzt so eine Schlagzeile kommen würde, Dagi Bee hat eine Eule totgetreten, würden die Leute sagen, die hat es immer noch drauf. Die mit ihren lustigen Pranks oder so. Es ist eigentlich wirklich, weil nichts kann ernst genommen werden. Niemand kann dir wirklich was tun. Es ist wie beim Charadespiel, ein Herzinfarkt bekommen und niemand hilft dir. Alle sagen, ein helftischer Anfall, Herzinfarkt. Jetzt mer Herzinfarkt. Nein, das stimmt. Ja, ziemlich genau das Leben. Und dann wieder selbst wiederbeleben. Grosses Problem. Okay, aber ist nicht so schlimm, oder? Also finden wir das schlimm? Menschen trennen sich, Menschen kommen zusammen, Menschen trennen sich. Ja, aber die waren das perfekte Paar und die haben alles zusammen gemacht. Hey, hey, komm. Die waren zusammen einkaufen. Hey, setz dich jetzt. Nein, aber ich meine... Setz dich, alles gut, komm. Die waren einfach die perfekte... Die waren zusammen einkaufen und das findest du toll? Die waren zusammen einkaufen und haben dann den Einkauf auf YouTube gezeigt. Und ich denke mir, das ist einfach unsere moderne Romeo und Julia so. Das ist einfach eine moderne Liebesgeschichte, die einfach funktioniert. Und deswegen... Wenn das das moderne Romeo und Julia ist, will ich mich umdringen. Es ist die schönste Liebesgeschichte unserer Zeit. Hey, ich werde dich nie verlassen. Ist das ein Prank? Ja. Prankst du mich? It's a fucking prank. War alles nur ein Prank. It's a prank. Wir sind übrigens schon seit drei Jahren getrennt. Wir haben das nur aufrechterhalten die ganze Zeit. Für die Posterverkäufe. Hast du von diesem Museum mitbekommen, wo der ein Fisch im Mixer kaputt getötet wurde? Das war das gruseligste. Du, ich hatte diese Woche nur Ohren für Dach. Kipferl, die Sagen sollen kaputt getötet, weil es echt tragisch ist. Aber es gab ein Kunstwerk, und das Kunstwerk ist wirklich spannend. In einem Kopenhagener Museum wurden fünf Mixer aufgestellt, in denen Wasser war und Goldfische. Und die waren alle angeschlossen. Das ist das beste Experiment ever. Ja, und es war so ein bisschen so, drückt jemand den Knopf. Und dann ging das auch lange gut, und dann irgendwann kam ein Besucher, und im Artikel stand nur, da hat der Besucher, irgendein Besucher hat er irgendwann auf den Knopf gedrückt und dann Überraschung, wurde der Fisch gemixt und war instant tot. Und das war ein großes Problem dann für das Museum, aber der Mann wurde nicht jetzt angeklagt, sondern der Museumsdirektor wurde angeklagt, weil der das ja dann quasi öffentlich zuhimmt gemacht hat. Aber meine Frage ist, hat sich der Typ, wann hat sich der Typ überlegt, diesen Fisch zu töten? War das eine impulsive, ich drück mal drauf, war es ein Versehen, irgendwie wurde geschubst, aufgedrückt, oder war es so ein, er hat sich morgens am Prüfstückstisch, hat er die Zeit gelesen und hat dann so gesehen, was die Kunstwerke sind, die gerade besprochen werden, die hat der neue heiße Scheiss und ist dann hingegangen und hat sich schon am Prüfstück überlegt, ich werde diesen Fisch umbringen. Was machst du? Ich weiß, im Museum ist ja so, du schaust ein Bild an und denkst, ich gucke mir erst mal alle anderen noch an, ob ich ein schöneres finde und dann stelle ich mich noch mal da vor. So hat er die gesehen, diese Fische und gedacht hat, ich gebe euch noch eine Chance, schaut sich noch mal alles andere an und vor allem welchen Fisch, welchen der fünf Fische hat er dann getötet? Wenn du schon sagst, ich töte jetzt einen Fisch, wir alle hatten den Gedanken, wer ist es, wonach machst du es fest? Der gemeine Fisch mit dem Bandana, der die ganze Zeit Mittelfinger zeigt. Du bist der, wer ist der Nächste, wer ist der Nächste? Aber auch diese Kinder, die davorstehen und sich wahrscheinlich über dieses Kunstwerk mehr freuen, als über irgendwelche Bilder und dann stehst du daneben und so ein Mann haut plötzlich auf diesen Filmer traumatisiert einfach auch. Ja, es ist schon schwierig, es ist schwierig, aber hat er das, hat er noch auch getrunken oder hat er also als als Fish Smoothie oder so einfach dann verkauft? Das stand auf den Regeln des Kunstwerks. Wer trinkt, muss auch trinken. Und dann, aber, aber das Beste von, wer drückt, muss auch trinken, so hieß das Kunstwerk.
Es ist jetzt, eine Plastik.
Entschuldigung, es ist jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich, dass Menschen Fische töten, um sie zu essen.
Also das wäre jetzt, also der Skandal wäre nicht so enorm gross.
Ne genau, also gemixt, getötet und dann vor Gericht gezogen und dann aber der Richter hat gesagt, dass der Fisch,
und ich weiss nicht, ob das eine gute Website war, wo ich es gelesen habe, aber er ist auf eine nicht unmenschliche Art gestorben. Und ich denke so, es ist ein Tier, also es kann auch nicht auf eine menschliche Art sterben, auf eine Art, aber es ist nicht, und ich dachte mir, was ist denn das Schlimmste, wenn die alle zugucken, wie du in tausend Einzelteile zerfetzt wirst, von einem Mixer, Und dann wurde die Mixerfirma vor das Gericht gezerrt, die erklären mussten, wie gut diese Mixer funktionieren und wie schnell die drehen. Das haben die gerne gemacht. Wie schnell wird das gemixt? Sehr schnell. Richtig schnell. Und dann haben die gesagt, dass der Mixero 3000 halt sehr schnell ist und sehr gut und dann hat der Richter gesagt, ja, aber da war es ja ein easy Tod. Aber was für ein Tod aufwachen, also super. Was für ein Job auch Richter ist, oder? Ja, mega. Du stehst einfach auf, ach, ein neuer Tag. So, Frau Guggenberg, was sind die Fälle heute? Also wir haben drei Fische, die in Mixern getötet wurden. Ach, fuck, das wäre einer dieser Tage. Wir haben einen berühmten Podcaster, der von einem uncoolen Mann und seiner Mastermind-Freundin auf einer Straße geprügelt wurde. Hat er einen Screenshot? Er hat einen Screenshot. Freispruch. Er ist einfach da. Dankeschön, Berlin. Leute, das war unsere Show. Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen. Fucking hell, what's fucking happening? What the fuck? Ich hätte so Angst, dass mir das mal irgendwann passiert. Was passiert? Es tut mir so leid. Am Rheinland-Pfalz-Tag habe ich gerade Berlin gesagt. Aber es tut mir so leid. Aber ich denke mir jedes Mal, wenn ich... Ich habe einmal Green Day Live gesehen und dachte mir, wenn denen das mal irgendwann passiert, wie peinlich das wäre, wenn die die falsche Stadt sagen.
Die einzige Person, die diese Show jetzt noch retten kann, ist die Frau ...
Fucking hell, meins.
... ist die Frau, die heute offensichtlich Besseres zu tun hat, als mit ihrem Sohn zu reden.
Ja, ist ja auch gebutt.
Die letzte Chance.
Bitte nicht jetzt. Ihr dürft aber nicht so laut sein, weil sonst ist die super desorientiert. Die macht sie dann Sorgen und denkt, oh, brennt es wieder bei dir, was ist da los? Ist das der böse Junge, von dem du mir erzählt hast? Nee, sie geht nicht an. Wenn sie jetzt nicht rangeht, wird das so antiklimatisch, ey. Dann kommen wir hier nie mehr raus. Wir wollten auf dem Lacher rausgehen. Zur Zeit ist erreichbar. Sie können nach dem Signalton eine Nachricht hinterlassen. Happy Birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday Frau Willow, happy birthday to you. Hi Mama, das war Mainz, wir sind gerade in einem Live-Podcast von Mainz. Ich mache so einen Podcast mit Stefan Tietze, das ist Stefan Tietze und wir wünschen ihr alles wahnsinnig alles Gute zum Geburtstag aus Mainz, halb Mainz ist hier versammelt, ich wünsche ihr einen schönen Tag. Das ist dein Applaus!
Ruf ich dich morgen an, das ist dein Applaus Mutter!
Vielleicht auch vorgestern, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht auch vorgestern. Mach's gut, ciao, ich wünsche noch einen schönen Tag, feier, mach's gut, ciao. Sehr schön. Das war unsere Show, mach's gut, Leute, ciao. Vielen Dank fürs Kommen, ihr wart fantastisch. Dankeschön. Haut rein, geniesst den Rheintag, macht's gut.
Dankeschön, das war Stefan Tietze und das war Florentin Will.
Vielen Dank. Dankeschön und ich würde sagen, wir heben ab.
Macht's gut!